en attendant Gérard Darmon va faire une
interview mensonges je peux laisser le
principe de mensonges il faut dire le
contraire de contraire de la vérité
c'est pas c'est pas ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous vous déplacez toujours en limousine
avec des vitres fumées et puis des gens
qui vous allez me comme ça vos
cigarettes
pourquoi c'est parce que ça fait ça fait
penser que c'est une star et vous devez
avoir tous ses attributs de la servitude
c'est quoi votre voiture limousine vous
allez toujours faire du tourisme sexuel
en Thaïlande
de participer au développement
économique du pays
si si je dis ça je ne peux je ne peux
pas me je ne peux pas dire le contraire
mais
vous partez seul à Bangkok pourquoi pas
avec des amis vous êtes misanthrope à ce
point-là exactement ça fait partie
plaisir que je ne partage pas donc vous
faites des choses tellement inavouables
là-bas que vous pouvez pas
puisque on peut en parler on parle de
tout
se
passe bien
ça se passe
des pâtes au beurre avec Delon et
Belmondo j'ai laissé tomber Vincent
Lindon Bacri Chabat en fait tous vos
copains pour qu'elle soit non parce que
je trouve intellectuellement beaucoup
plus faible que que la bande à laquelle
vous faites allusion
que c'est
comme ça
il
y a pas de problème
on peut le dire je crois que c'est ça
c'est bientôt à gauche
dans le domaine philosophique sur le
conte philosophique de très intéressé
par cornichon sur le surhomme
je partage
mon ami pour
vous
c'est de la merde
pourquoi
est-ce que ça durait longtemps parce
qu'il était gros plan d'eau plein de que
j'adore j'adore les sucreries voilà si
je peux tout faire en bouffon de Las
Vegas
mais pour être sûr de ne rien rater
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu